what a lovely day hey guys so we're
gonna watch the trailer for george
miller mad max fury road director three
thousand miles three thousand years of
longing i know literally nothing about
this but it's george miller songs like
we gotta check it out because it's
probably a little bit bonkers but before
we do that i want to thank the sponsor
today this is a different kind of thing
we're doing it's shutter they have an
original movie out on their platform
right now called the sadness long story
short here's what happened we were asked
to do a trailer reaction for them nine
times out of ten we don't agree to those
just because that usually means it's an
awful trick
so what we did was like we'll watch it
first we'll record a reaction and if we
end up liking it then we will we'll
submit it to them that ended up being
the case and so what we're going to do
for you guys is after we cover this we
will show you our reaction for that
trailer and you can decide if you want
to go to shutter sign up for them so you
could go watch the original film but i'm
warning you it's a hard redband trailer
it's really it's hardcore very nasty uh
but boy did a generator reaction anywho
we will show you guys that afterwards
but in the meantime let's get to three
thousand
yep yeah
[Music]
my name is alaphia
my story is true
i am a solitary creature by nature
i have no children or siblings nor
parents
i did once have a husband
if there is fate who can say
but in the grand bazaar of istanbul
i chose a memento
whatever it is i'm sure it has an
interesting story
uh-oh
[Music]
yeah it's a genie movie
wow
so what would you wish for what is your
heart's desire
wow creepy good question
what does one do with three wishes
you'll see
[Music]
[Music]
there's no story about wishing that is
not a cautionary tale
we all have desires even if they remain
hidden from us
but it is your story and
i cannot wait to see where it goes oh
you're gonna make some twists and wishes
does it have to even end
[Music]
oh
hello
he'll be staying for a while
yeah stretch those wishes out
i'm beginning to wish we never met
don't say that oh
[Music]
i have a wish
oh
god
oh my goodness tanks like zack snyder
wes anderson and torch miller had a
threesome
that's all i've ever won
that's all i've ever wanted in the
theater
that was wild that was nuts i love it
because it starts off as like this
wonder wish fulfillment and then you
just watch it descend like it's george
miller who's done things like bay pig in
the city so you know
what happy february yeah
for a second i was like oh
is this one of those george miller
movies yeah
and then as it kept going like oh no
we're gonna get some like sexual stuff
in here oh we're gonna get some like
graphic horror stuff in here oh we're
getting some trippy mind-bending stuff i
love that like it starts off oh i got
three wishes and they were really
selling me on the the beauty and the and
the wonder fulfillment of it and then it
starts to go down a depraved path as
opposed to like something like mad max 3
0 which starts off just you know bad
[ __ ] right away that seems like it's
going gonna descend into batshit yeah
yeah yeah no i'm i'm excited because
this looks really wild and really
colorful in a way that seems very
indicative of george miller's status as
an auteur and something that takes
advantage of the three wishes you know
genie gin kind of tale in that i feel
like it's easy you know to kind of
ground that in just the time and place
that whatever character is in but it
looks like these wishes are gonna take
us to all sorts of different times
places you know circumstances of reality
and so i'm just really excited to see
what his imagination can take us to
because is this the first
film he's directed since fury wrote
because i feel like based off the
success of that he probably got to do
whatever he wanted to do with this yeah
and that gets me really excited because
george miller is like 80s now but that
guy is still as sharp as ever from what
i can tell and this looks really
beautifully realized and herself is a
perfect casting until the swim watching
them bounce up maybe i just thought wes
anderson because until this win this is
like one of those big hollywood
production movies that i'm worried might
not make enough money super artsy it's
okay that'll force him to go back to mad
max yeah he's like fine i'll do my
furiosa
all right guys what did you think about
this trailer are you looking forward to
it now um we will show you our reaction
for the sadness
three two one and
shudder original
[Music]
what a good looking couple yeah
nothing bad's gonna happen today
[Music]
is it like the crazies
[Music]
what is it
oh my god
are we sure these are zombies
they're so demented
more like them
[Music]
jeez that was disgusting hardcore that
was gross that was
there's so many things oh my gosh so
yeah originally that was just going to
be submitted to them to use for their
own purposes but we wanted to share it
here
i figured whatever mgm they're not going
to let us monetize it anyway
i might as well get
yeah but uh i i want to check it out
i've heard uh that is is as insane as
the movie actually looks in the footage
itself thank you guys so much for being
here thank you to shutter for sponsoring
they have a whole bunch of other titles
as well as two horror fanatics we
already have our own shutter
subscriptions shutter is a very reliable
source for horror entertainment hit that
link in the box do it guys do it we're
not the first people you've heard about
shutter from so if you're in a horror
they're the streaming servers you ought
to have yeah man
all right guys
thank you so much for being here and uh
we will catch you all soon